[Music]
so I I'm not a crossword editor I'm a
games platform engineer here at the
times and this is a talk about how we
built a recursive bigquery mapper to
move our data around in GCP a little bit
of background first crossword went out
in 1913 and then in 1924 crossword
editor called it a sinful waste of time
he did not like it took up space in the
newspaper and then Pearl Harbor happened
and The Times decided that it was a nice
thing to include in the paper to give
people something to look forward to when
they opened it up and in 1997 the
crossword went digital
it was released online on the web first
and then a long time later iOS and
Android came around and eventually we
launched the mini which is a 5 by 5
crossword today we support all of these
platforms PDFs web mobile web Android
iOS Kindle and Windows so a lot of users
spread across a lot of different
platforms which makes our infrastructure
a little more complicated
the background of this talk is that we
recently did an entire replied form from
was essentially a lamp stack on AWS to
GCP the times as a whole is moving
towards GCP so this just follows in line
with that it was a long complicated
endeavor or there's lots of different
phases lots of different moving data
around and you know launching new
services and shifting traffic and
eventually it came to look something
like this this is actually kind of
outdated there's a lot more to it now
but we've got micro services they're all
written and go they all run on App
Engine and our source of truth is
datastore which is a Google's document
store with memcache in front of it so
the problem is when we went from a lamp
stack to GCP with datastore we migrated
from my sequel to datastore and we lost
the ability to run
complex bespoke queries against our data
datastore is great like give me the
puzzle for this day giving me the
progress for this user and this puzzle
but you can't run aggregations across
the entire data set you need something
else for that
so the swimwear is datastore and the
somewhere else that we need it is
bigquery we really want to be able to do
these analytics across all of our users
or all of our puzzles and get those deep
insights that we used to have the first
solution that we had in GCP you can
launch a backup of data store and load
it into bigquery it's just you go into
the admin you click start back up and
then you let it run for a little while
every GCP or every App Engine project on
GCP has a what's called a default
service just one that you just have to
pick one
as it happens our default service is our
edge layer so when we kicked it off we
stopped paying attention to it and then
a few minutes later we started getting
tons of alerts because our default edge
server the latency went from about 100
milliseconds to over 10 seconds because
what GCP did was it launched all these
mapping jobs in the background on our
default service to move this data around
we found that it's incredibly slow way
too slow for our needs the default
version is in Python they have a Java
version but they don't really tell you
how to deploy it and we're a go shop we
don't write Java we don't we don't want
to write Java and it just does a backup
it doesn't do anything fancy and the
thing we really wanted was we wanted
streaming all new data going forward not
just historical this is kind of the
inspiration for the project
whoever captain code man is they wrote a
go version of this Python mapper which
we considered using problem as its third
party and then we'd have probably to
fork it to extend it to do the things
that we want the one thing I want to
call out is that has read me he says
that this was able to process about one
point six thousand entities per second
so that was kind of like our baseline
for performance for this
so we're gonna write our round we're
gonna write our own mapper we're gonna
deploy it to App Engine and we're gonna
use this to move our data between
datastore and bigquery we wanted to look
a little bit like this where you can
call an endpoint to kick off a job with
a data type that you want to move around
a start timestamp and an end time stamp
so you just do bulk loads of like you
know a month's worth of data or days
worth of data that's kind of what the
implant looks like you it looks for that
path and it accepted get requests and
calls that Lutz chorus function real
quickly we found out that so much data
is being moved around that you can't do
this in a single request App Engine has
a hard-coded 60 second time-out on an
HTTP request from just the outside web
so that didn't work so we needed some
kind of fan-out system so a request
comes in usually from us we query for
all the keys in datastore not the
entities just the keys now what we're
going to do is we're gonna publish those
keys out to pub/sub I don't know if
you're here for the talk yesterday but
pub/sub is basically TCPS message broker
but it really is the way to describe
just a sponge it's a place that you send
all of your data to be processed at some
point whenever some subscriber is ready
to do it so we posted mountain batches
of say 500 what the pub slab is going to
do is actually we've set up our service
to not only be the producer of these
messages we've also set up to be the
consumer of all the messages so when the
when we publish all the pub/sub they're
actually going to flood back into the
service that we set up and it's gonna
use the keys that it accepts on the
ingress to grab the entities out of
datastore and put them into bigquery so
now it looks something like this where
we kick off the job it starts publishing
out keys to pub/sub and then the keys
are gonna flood back into the service
App Engine you guys see all of these
requests coming in and it's gonna
automatically and very quickly scale
itself up to handle the load and it's
just going to keep scaling
as long as it has to and now that we've
got all these instances they can go and
grab all the data that we need out of
datastore and put it into bigquery and
it's pretty fast but it's not fast
enough and the problem is we found that
when we're loading a lot of data
the initial HTTP HTTP request that we
use to kick off the job only has 60
seconds we found that that 60 seconds
but sometimes not enough to publish all
of the keys we needed so that request
would die not all the keys would be
published all the rest of the jobs would
finish up all these App Engine instances
would go away and the job isn't complete
so we needed to figure out a way to fan
out even more and what we found is that
pub/sub is great for publishing messages
and assuming that they'll be taken care
of eventually kind of just a
fire-and-forget system but we wanted was
something with a little more control
about how we can use it and that's what
task queue is it's similar it's they're
almost interchangeable in some places
but Tess queue gives you a lot more
control over how your data is handled so
then you algorithm that we came up with
is that if a request calls for a range
of data that we've determined is too
large what we want to do is we want to
chunk up that time range into smaller
time ranges publish them to task queue
and then we're basically going to do the
same thing so we post them to task queue
we ingest those task queue job tasks
essentially use the new date range to
create for the keys publish the keys out
to pub/sub and the requests come back in
we scale herself up use the keys same
thing we did before and GCP to step to
set up a task queue I have to do is add
this animal the one thing I want to call
out is that the rate tess queue has a
maximum post rate of 500 per second so
if you put you put as many messages or
tests on it as you want but they'll only
flow back out at a rate
maximum 500 per second and they have
retries and everything this is kind of
what it looks like if we decided that
the date range is larger than say one
hour we're going to create a publisher
initialize or or sorry if it's less than
an hour we're going to initialize our
publisher and just publish post the keys
straight up out to pub/sub otherwise
we're gonna have to start in queuing
them on to test queue we give it an
endpoint path the total start and end
date for the entire query and the chunk
size which is one hour and it's kind of
what this looks like it's going to
create the path and just start creating
these post tasks and putting them onto
task queue in smaller chunks of the
original time range and a great thing
about this is that if we were gonna use
pub/sub again we would have to there's a
little bit overhead with that we'd have
to create new endpoints because yeah
there's creating line points we'd have
to create a struct for the payload that
comes in we'd have to have like encoders
and decoders for the messages that are
coming where's all the data that we
really want is just these start and end
time stamps and all we had to do was add
the ability for this endpoint to handle
post requests and bam it's the same
thing so now we've got App Engine
posting to task queue which then posts
its task back to App Engine which scales
up a little bit which then repost all of
their - their keys out - pub/sub which
doesn't flood back in so it scales it
scales at scales keep scaling itself as
long as it has to so now it's really
fast and our benchmarking we found that
it can load things in a big query at a
rate of 25,000 keys per second and it's
actually we found that it's too fast
bigquery has a 10 megabyte per second
stream limit which we would blow through
very quickly since this thing is
basically infinitely scalable so we
actually one of the reasons we use task
queue is that you can actually turn down
the rate very easily gives you that
really fine
to say how quickly you actually want
your data to be processed so we turned
it down to one per second one date range
and that shut up all the alerts that we
would get whenever it was trying to load
data to fast here's kind of what it
looks like in the logs see at the bottom
there's a get request that just says
here's a start timestamp and give me all
the data between then and now and then
the task queue post requests are coming
in afterward with chunked up time ranges
if you click on one of them you can see
that at the bottom it queried for all
the keys within that time range and it
published all the keys out pops up this
one published 97 thousand keys in about
40 seconds and then on the other end
when the pub/sub request comes back in
it had a request it had 500 keys and the
payload it grabbed 500 scores in this
case grabbing around a datastore put
them into bigquery and this is just what
the so look I mentioned we wanted to be
able to handle streaming new data into
bigquery
so what solve happens whenever you
finish the game so when you when we
detect that you've solved the crossword
we're gonna publish something called a
score the score just has some summary
data about the game that you played how
long you played you know did you cheat
whatever and that is gonna that's
published by another one of our services
and our bigquery service is a subscriber
to that topic and what it's going to do
is it's gonna take your score put that
in a big query and it's also going to
use the metadata from the score to grab
your progress which is the basically
summer summary state of your board put
that into bigquery for analytics and
it's also gonna grab all of your what we
call progress commits which are
snapshots that we take of your game over
time and the reason this was such a
for us is because these snapshots in
particular they all have a full copy of
your crossword board with a ton of other
metadata involved so it's a very it's
not a trivial thing to load in bulk
across services the other really cool
thing we were able to do is we're able
to give it a user ID and we can actually
go back in time and load all of the data
for a particular user we've used this a
lot when someone will email us and say
hey I've been doing the crossword online
forever but I only see that I have like
a 99.4% solve rate as in in all the
archive that we have I'm missing one or
two puzzles somewhere I really want to
go back and finish let me get that a
hundred percent salt right so we can
actually use this to load all of that
users data going all the way back in
time loaded into bigquery and query and
figure out what puzzles from 2012 that
this person was missing this is kind
what it looks like so we set this up on
a nightly cron everyday around 3:00 a.m.
it's gonna go and load all the progress
scores and parse commits for the
previous day so you can see every day at
3:00 a.m. it's gonna scale up to about
sixty instances on tone do all the
loading and then instantly scale back
down actually what you can see is that
this it's kind of evenly spaced except
for the second one on the right that one
is actually kind of anomaly and what
happened was another engineer act
actually ended up adding two fields to
our progress struct which meant that it
no longer in the code matched the schema
in bigquery so bigquery was rejecting
every single request so you can see that
it just started to stack up the queue
size in pub/sub but the great thing
about pub/sub is that it's super
resilient and it's gonna hold onto all
these messages for at least seven days
and it's just gonna keep retrying them
again and again and right there at the
end you see that I fixed the issue
the fields in bigquery and then BAM like
it flushed them all back out of the
queue into bigquery in one big one big
scoop so some of the cool things that
we've actually been able to learn about
our users or maybe a lot of these things
we had suspected but it's great now that
we actually have the data to back it up
so we segmented users into novice who
have completed lesson seven puzzles and
experts who have played more than seven
puzzles in the past month and as you can
see that novice users spend way more
time solving the puzzles and advanced
users they spend about 40 minutes on
average and expert users spend less than
about 35 almost half of all novice users
have to reveal a puzzle at some point to
get it solved where it's about you know
only a quarter of experts and novice
users abandon the puzzle a lot they just
54% just don't finish their puzzles and
whereas experts will finish about 80% of
the time you can't see this in graph
form so you can see that novice users in
the top left give up very quickly
and it seems that like after you get to
about the 50% board filled state you
pretty much guaranteed to finish it
whereas experts they finish if they
start a puzzle either abandon it right
away sometimes or they're almost
guaranteed to finish it and you can see
that on the bottom left novice users are
way more prone to cheating than expert
users and so you can see that the
Saturday is the light blue on the top
people are much more likely to cheat on
a Saturday than they are to Monday if
you don't know crossword puzzles get
harder throughout the week so Monday is
the easiest Saturday is the hardest and
some day is generally not as hard a
puzzle the clues are hard but it is much
bigger so it had it's difficult in that
way yeah so now we can segment users
into the
soft quantiles the gist of this is that
if you can solve a crossword puzzle in
about seven-and-a-half minutes you're in
the top one percent of all solvers
across the world and if you can do it in
30 minutes you're still top fifty
percent and here you can see how the
difficulty goes up throughout time so
the first day of the week is Sunday you
can see Sunday's a bigger puzzle so it
usually takes people about an hour to do
but Monday is a much easier puzzle only
takes people about 16 minutes and these
are solves without reveals so people who
solved it and did not cheat and we can
also compare quantiles across time so
this is a chart that compares one mini
puzzle of today versus the same day of
the week last week so the yellow is last
week the blue is today and you can see
that last week's puzzle was apparently
way harder than today's puzzle and I
want to give a shout out we are hiring
we have a lot of open positions in all
sorts of technologies but we write a lot
of go and do a lot of cool things at the
times thank you
[Applause]
is there a reason that you can't use the
task queues for the places in the code
where you use the pub/sub no there's no
reason we just when we started out we
wanted that kind of infinite scalability
captain code man third party ever looked
at exclusively used tasks keys hi what
is your feeling of AWS versus GCP I
haven't had a chance to interact with
AWS as much as GCP this definitely isn't
an argument to say that GCP is better
than AWS the takeaway is just that our
the legacy lamp stack that we had was
not performing the way that we had that
we required anymore and we wanted to
leverage the new technology of GCP
service mark you know micro services all
the other you know hot new technology
but the nice thing about GCP is really a
pinch an app engine is a really really
easy platform to develop on and a very
has a lot of really advanced tools the
logging is very advanced you get extra
logs and you get stackdriver for free so
we like it in those respects how do you
do you use gold routine within your pall
from the data store and how do you
ensure that 60 minutes time now is
enforced the with endo every request we
don't enforce it App Engine itself
enforces it do we use go routines yes to
some extent but we usually find that
they're not necessary the last thing we
want is messin with a bunch of
concurrency primitives within our code
and the go servers are already handling
every request in separate go routine
it's my understanding that the
architecture is supporting at at least
one so there may be a chance of
duplication how do you maintain
idempotency here we essentially there's
no good way to t do data when it gets
into datastore we've come to terms with
that you essentially just have to be
careful when you query to query across
unique keys and you use group bys and
distinct
hi I'm not 100% sure like why when we
are loading it to datastore you cannot
also load it to bigquery is there like a
reason that it's so decoupled well we
wanted this to be an offline system we
wouldn't want to be putting essentially
a backup within the hot path of our
service we like to keep latency as low
as possible especially because we
released a new puzzle at 10 p.m. every
night and you'll see a massive spike in
traffic and we definitely don't want to
interfere with that by it was
essentially a backup offline job
I your thoughts on using go versus Java
or C++ for your internal development
there we are very big fans of go we've
developed a lot of tooling around it we
developed the drone App Engine plugin
just written go we find that the tools
out of the box are really good in terms
of profiling memory management just
recently we used P prof tools to track
down memory leak that we were having so
in that respect go is very very useful
for very quick application development
as a whole the New York Times does use
Java and Scala to some extent but go has
become the language of choice for I
would say most developers and most teams
at this point
[Music]